- Bienvenido a Comprender
la Información y la Computación Cuántica.
Mi nombre es John Watrous, y soy el director técnico
de IBM Quantum Education.
El propósito de esta serie es brindarte
una comprensión sólida de la información y la computación cuántica, lo que significa adentrarse
en los detalles técnicos
de la información cuántica y ver cómo la computación
cuántica realmente funciona, qué puede hacer y qué no puede hacer.
Si aún no has visto
el video de introducción de esta serie, te animo a que lo revises.
En ese video encontrarás información sobre qué tipo de preparación previa
se recomienda para esta serie, así como un esquema de
los temas que se cubrirán.
Además, asegúrate de revisar
el libro de texto de Qiskit, que cubre el mismo
material que esta serie de videos en formato escrito,
y también incluye
componentes interactivos e interfaces de hardware y software diseñados para ayudarte a comprender mejor
la información y la computación cuántica. Encontrarás enlaces al video de introducción y al libro de texto de Qiskit
en la descripción.
Esta es la lección uno de
la unidad uno de la serie.
La unidad uno cubre los fundamentos
de la información cuántica, y en la primera lección de esta unidad nos centraremos en cómo
funciona la información cuántica
para sistemas individuales, lo que significa que tenemos
un solo sistema físico o un dispositivo de algún tipo que
almacena información cuántica
y estamos considerando cómo funciona ese
único sistema o dispositivo de forma aislada.
En la lección siguiente a esta, discutiremos cómo
funciona la información cuántica cuando tenemos múltiples sistemas, y eso nos permitirá
describir conceptos interesantes
e importantes, como algoritmos cuánticos que hacen uso de múltiples qubits
y protocolos cuánticos
que involucran a múltiples individuos que procesan información cuántica y la transmiten de un lado
a otro entre sí.
Pero antes de entrar en esas discusiones, tiene sentido comenzar con el
entorno comparativamente simple de un sistema individual de forma aislada,
en parte porque es bueno empezar de forma sencilla, pero también porque, como veremos, la descripción de cómo
funciona la información cuántica
para sistemas individuales de forma aislada conduce de manera muy natural y lógica a la descripción de cómo
para múltiples sistemas.
Aquí hay un breve resumen de la lección.
Vamos a comenzar discutiendo
la información clásica.
El propósito de esta lección no es explicar cómo
funciona la información clásica, sino explicar cómo
funciona la información cuántica,
pero para explicar cómo
funciona la información cuántica, es muy útil comenzar
con la información clásica y usarla como un
punto de referencia familiar
cuando hablemos de información cuántica.
A nivel matemático, la información cuántica y la clásica tienen descripciones bastante similares, con algunas diferencias clave, por supuesto.
De hecho, la información cuántica
realmente no está separada de la información clásica en absoluto.
Es una extensión de
la información clásica.
La realidad del asunto
es, al menos desde mi punto de vista, que realmente no puedes
entender la información cuántica si no entiendes
la información clásica,
así que comenzar con la información clásica
tiene sentido.
Sí espero que este
contenido les resulte familiar a algunos espectadores, pero incluso si ya lo conoces, no te recomiendo que lo omitas.
Además de destacar los aspectos de la información clásica que son más relevantes para
entender la información cuántica, vamos a introducir la
notación de Dirac en esta parte,
que es la forma estándar
que usaremos para describir vectores y
matrices a lo largo de la serie.
Resulta que la notación de Dirac no es
específica de la información cuántica.
Puede usarse igualmente bien en el contexto de la información clásica, así como en muchos otros entornos donde surgen vectores y matrices.
Luego pasaremos a la información cuántica y, específicamente,
discutiremos la representación de los estados cuánticos como vectores,
un tipo simple de medición llamado medición de base estándar, y las operaciones unitarias, que describen cambios en el tiempo discreto
en sistemas cuánticos.
Todo esto, de nuevo, en el contexto
de sistemas individuales.
Antes de que comencemos con la lección en sí, será útil aclarar que en realidad existen dos descripciones
de la información cuántica: la descripción simplificada, que es en la que nos
centraremos en esta lección
y a lo largo de esta primera unidad, y la descripción general, que se cubre en una unidad posterior, específicamente en la
tercera unidad de la serie.
La descripción simplificada,
fiel a su nombre, es más sencilla y es
la que se aprende primero típicamente.
En la descripción simplificada, como ya he sugerido, los estados cuánticos se representan mediante vectores y las operaciones se representan
mediante matrices unitarias.
Esta descripción de la información
cuántica es suficiente para comprender
la mayoría de los algoritmos cuánticos, por ejemplo,
así que no está sobresimplificada, es la cosa real.
Sin embargo, como iremos
descubriendo a medida que avancemos, sí tiene algunas limitaciones.
Por ejemplo, si queremos
modelar los efectos del ruido en los sistemas cuánticos, esta descripción resulta ser insuficiente.
La descripción general, por otro lado,
es más general y, en última instancia, es más
poderosa en un sentido matemático.
En esta descripción, los estados cuánticos se representan mediante una clase especial de matrices
llamadas matrices de densidad,
y se puede describir una clase más general de
mediciones y operaciones, incluyendo
el ruido, por ejemplo.
Es completamente compatible con
la descripción simplificada y, de hecho, se puede ver
esencialmente la descripción simplificada
como un caso especial de
la descripción general, y también incluye la información clásica como un caso especial.
También es realmente bastante
hermosa en cómo funciona todo, así que te animo a aprender sobre esta descripción general
cuando sea el momento adecuado, pero la descripción simplificada es el punto de partida más natural, y eso es lo que vamos a hacer.
Vamos a empezar hablando sobre la información clásica, con la vista puesta en los aspectos
de la información clásica que son más relevantes
para la información cuántica
y la forma en que se
describe matemáticamente.
Imagina que tenemos un
sistema físico o algún tipo de dispositivo que almacena información.
Le vamos a dar a este sistema el nombre X, pero no hay nada
importante en este nombre.
Podríamos usar cualquier otro
nombre si lo prefiriéramos, pero simplemente para elegir un nombre,
vamos a llamar al sistema X.
Vamos a hacer una suposición sobre X, que es que existe un
conjunto finito de estados clásicos en los que X puede estar
en cualquier momento dado.
Aquí, cuando me refiero a un estado clásico, me refiero a una configuración del sistema que puede reconocerse y
describirse sin ambigüedad
sin ninguna incertidumbre ni error.
Realmente, esto es algo en lo que puedes pensar de forma intuitiva. A nivel matemático, simplemente definimos el
conjunto de estados clásicos,
lo elegimos como queramos o de la manera que mejor
describa el dispositivo con el que estamos trabajando.
Démosle el nombre sigma a
este conjunto de estados clásicos y, de nuevo, déjame enfatizar
que estamos asumiendo que sigma es un conjunto finito.
El conjunto de estados clásicos
de este sistema X no es infinitamente grande como
el conjunto de todos los números naturales.
Es finito, y esa es simplemente
una suposición que estamos haciendo.
Por ejemplo, podría ser que X sea un bit, en cuyo caso, el conjunto de estados clásicos es el conjunto que contiene dos
elementos: cero y uno.
A veces nos referimos a este
conjunto como el alfabeto binario.
Otro ejemplo es que X es
un dado ordinario de seis caras, en cuyo caso, los estados clásicos son los números del uno al seis.
Por supuesto, estamos hablando
de una abstracción aquí.
Un dado real de seis caras puede
tener muchos atributos diferentes, como su posición exacta,
su orientación,
su temperatura, y demás. Pero con respecto a la información que es más típicamente relevante cuando hablamos de un dado de seis caras,
los estados clásicos son
los números del uno al seis, indicados por la cantidad de puntos en el lado del dado que está mirando hacia arriba.
Si X es un interruptor de un
ventilador eléctrico estándar que podrías tener en tu casa, entonces quizás los estados clásicos
son las configuraciones alto,
medio, bajo y apagado.
Estos son solo ejemplos. Podríamos imaginar sistemas con conjuntos de estados clásicos
diferentes a estos, pero con suerte, transmiten la idea
de que esta noción de estado clásico es algo que debería ser
familiar y puede entenderse en términos simples e intuitivos.
Matemáticamente hablando, el conjunto de estados clásicos
es simplemente un conjunto finito y, por supuesto, este conjunto también debe
ser no vacío.
Tiene que haber al menos
un estado clásico en el que el sistema pueda estar y tiene que haber al menos
dos estados clásicos
si el sistema va a ser útil para almacenar información.
Ahora bien, en algunas situaciones, podríamos saber que X está
en algún estado particular, pero en muchas situaciones,
que surgen en el contexto
del procesamiento de información, puede haber incertidumbre sobre el estado clásico de un
sistema en un momento particular
de modo que cada posible estado clásico tiene alguna probabilidad asociada a él.
Por ejemplo, si X es un bit, entonces quizás X está en el estado clásico cero
con probabilidad tres cuartos y está en el estado uno
con probabilidad un cuarto.
Vamos a referirnos a esto
como un estado probabilístico, y podemos expresar
este estado probabilístico, como ves aquí,
simplemente indicando cuáles
son las probabilidades para los diferentes estados clásicos.
Una forma más concisa de expresar
este estado probabilístico es mediante un vector, específicamente la representación
que ves aquí
es un vector columna, y este vector indica
cuáles son las probabilidades para los dos posibles estados clásicos.
Para ser más específico, la primera entrada indica
cuál es la probabilidad de que X esté en el estado cero, y la segunda entrada nos dice
cuál es la probabilidad
de que el sistema esté en el estado uno. Esta es simplemente la forma natural de ordenar el alfabeto binario,
o al menos, es la forma en que
estamos entrenados para hacerlo. Con el cero primero y el uno segundo.
En adelante, vamos a usar
el término vector de probabilidad para referirnos a un vector como este.
Específicamente, es un vector cuyas entradas son todas
números reales no negativos y donde la suma de las
entradas es igual a uno,
así que tiene sentido pensar
en estas entradas como probabilidades.
En este ejemplo hay solo dos entradas porque solo hay dos
estados clásicos del sistema del que hablamos,
pero en general puede haber
cualquier cantidad de entradas, entendiendo
que hay una entrada por cada estado clásico
del sistema del que estemos hablando.
Vamos a seguir
hablando de información clásica, vectores de probabilidad y
demás en un momento, pero antes, va a ser muy útil
introducir cierta notación
para describir vectores, conocida como la notación de Dirac.
De hecho, esta es solo la primera
parte de la notación de Dirac.
Hay un par de otros
aspectos de la notación de Dirac que veremos un poco
más adelante en la lección.
Esta notación va a ser
bastante central en la forma en que describimos la información cuántica, así que es esencial
entender cómo funciona,
pero afortunadamente es muy simple y realmente no tiene
nada que ver específicamente con la información cuántica,
así que podemos introducirla ahora
en el contexto familiar de la información clásica.
Como antes, asumimos que tenemos un conjunto sigma de
estados clásicos de algún sistema, y asumamos
que tenemos un ordenamiento
de estos estados clásicos, igual que cuando nos referimos a un
ordenamiento del alfabeto binario
en el ejemplo anterior. Otra forma de decir esto
es que los elementos de sigma se ponen en correspondencia
con el entero
desde uno hasta la cantidad de
elementos que contiene sigma, que es lo que significa esta notación de aquí con las dos barras alrededor de sigma.
Ese es el número de
elementos en el conjunto sigma.
Así que hay un primer estado,
un segundo estado, y así sucesivamente.
El ordenamiento específico o
la correspondencia que elijamos no va a importar demasiado.
Lo que realmente importa es
que tengamos un ordenamiento y nos atengamos a él.
Para muchos conjuntos de estados clásicos
que encontraremos, habrá un ordenamiento estándar tal como tenemos con
el alfabeto binario,
y si no hay un ordenamiento estándar, simplemente podemos elegir uno.
Pero sea cual sea, el acuerdo es que nos atenemos a él.
Ahora bien, aquí está la notación
que vamos a introducir.
Para cualquier elección de un estado
clásico a de nuestro conjunto sigma, escribimos esto de aquí, que se lee como ket a,
para referirnos al vector columna
que tiene un uno en la entrada correspondiente a a y un cero para todas las demás entradas.
Por ejemplo, si volvemos
al alfabeto binario, que, como ya habrás imaginado, es un ejemplo muy importante
al que volveremos una y otra vez. Entonces ket zero y ket one son los vectores que se definen aquí.
Ket zero es el vector
que tiene un uno en la entrada correspondiente al estado clásico zero, que es la primera entrada,
y un cero para todas las demás entradas, y en este caso solo
hay una entrada más.
De manera similar, ket one es
este vector de aquí, donde tenemos un uno en la
entrada correspondiente a one,
que es la segunda entrada, y un cero para todas las demás entradas, que, de nuevo, es solo una entrada.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo. En este ejemplo, tenemos un
conjunto de estados clásicos sigma correspondiente a los cuatro palos
de una baraja estándar de cartas: tréboles, diamantes, corazones y espadas.
En este caso, realmente no hay un
ordenamiento universalmente acordado de estos palos.
En muchos juegos de cartas no hay ningún ordenamiento. Son simplemente cuatro palos distintos y eso es todo lo que importa, y hay diferentes juegos de cartas
que sí ordenan estos palos
de formas distintas, pero realmente no importa.
Simplemente podemos elegir un
ordenamiento como el que ves aquí.
Este resulta ser el orden alfabético según los nombres de estos cuatro palos escritos en inglés,
suponiendo que hemos elegido
este ordenamiento en particular, entonces definimos estos cuatro vectores: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts y ket spades
como ves aquí, y estos vectores corresponden
a la descripción general que ves arriba.
Dado que hemos elegido
este ordenamiento en particular para estos cuatro palos.
Podemos hacer lo mismo para cualquier conjunto de estados clásicos
que elijamos.
Teniendo en cuenta que un conjunto de estados clásicos
siempre significa un conjunto finito y no vacío.
Los vectores de esta forma se
llaman vectores de base estándar, y es un hecho muy básico sobre los vectores que todo vector puede
expresarse de forma única
como una combinación lineal
de vectores de base estándar.
Por ejemplo, volviendo al ejemplo de hace un momento, el vector de probabilidad
que vimos puede expresarse
como ves aquí. Es básicamente solo una forma alternativa de expresar vectores
que va a ser muy útil por varias razones de aquí en adelante.
Y con esa notación ya en nuestras manos, volvamos a la discusión
de la información clásica y los estados probabilísticos, en particular.
Y consideremos qué sucede
cuando medimos un sistema mientras está en algún estado probabilístico.
Puede que normalmente no
nos refiramos a una medición o al acto de medir
algo en un contexto clásico, pero el término tiene sentido.
En esencia, cuando hablamos
de medir el sistema X en este contexto, simplemente queremos decir que lo observamos y reconocemos en qué estado se encuentra.
Por supuesto, cuando observamos el sistema, no vemos un estado probabilístico, sino un estado clásico,
y el estado clásico particular
que vemos es uno que podemos
imaginar que se elige aleatoriamente según las probabilidades.
Ahora bien, quizás puedas objetar desde un punto de vista filosófico a la idea de que el estado clásico que vemos es elegido de alguna manera al azar
en el momento en que medimos u observamos el sistema, el sistema simplemente estaba en algún estado clásico particular todo el tiempo
y simplemente resulta que
hemos descubierto cuál era el estado, pero a efectos de pensar sobre el marco
matemático con el que trabajamos,
está bien pensarlo de esta manera y hacerlo nos permitirá trazar un paralelismo con
la información cuántica un poco más adelante.
Supongamos que el
estado clásico que vemos es el estado clásico a, que podría ser cualquier estado en nuestro conjunto sigma.
Esto cambia el estado probabilístico
de X en general, al menos desde nuestro punto de vista.
Las probabilidades ya no
tienen ningún significado porque ahora sabemos cuál
es el estado clásico de X.
Es a, y ya no hay
ninguna incertidumbre al respecto.
Así que ahora diríamos
que la probabilidad de que el sistema esté en el estado a es uno.
Lo sabemos porque acabamos de observarlo y vimos que el estado clásico es a, por lo que el nuevo estado probabilístico de X es uno
en el que la probabilidad de
estar en el estado clásico a es igual a uno.
Y ese estado probabilístico está representado por el
vector de probabilidad ket a.
Tenemos un uno en la entrada correspondiente al estado clásico a y un cero en todas las demás entradas.
Por ejemplo, si de nuevo
consideramos la situación en la que X es un bit y tenemos el mismo
estado probabilístico de antes,
entonces si medimos X, podemos imaginar que se produce una
transición.
Con probabilidad tres cuartos, vemos el estado clásico cero, y al medir, hacemos la transición a ket cero
como nuestro estado probabilístico,
y con probabilidad un cuarto, hacemos la transición a ket uno.
Puedes pensarlo como una transición de conocimiento si lo prefieres, en lugar de una
transición física real,
pero lo importante para
esta lección es reconocer cómo funciona la matemática.
En realidad es bastante trivial, pero al reconocer esta trivialidad, la descripción análoga
para el ámbito cuántico
puede parecer un poco menos misteriosa.
Una nota final es que para otra persona que no haya visto cuál
era el estado clásico de X cuando lo medimos,
el estado probabilístico
naturalmente no cambiaría como resultado de que lo hayamos medido.
Eso está bien. Distintos individuos pueden
tener distintos conocimientos de un sistema particular y, en consecuencia, elegir
distintos estados probabilísticos
para representar su
conocimiento de ese sistema.
En la última parte de esta discusión sobre información clásica, hablaremos de las operaciones clásicas que se pueden realizar sobre un sistema,
comenzando con las operaciones deterministas.
Cuando realizamos una operación sobre un sistema, su estado generalmente cambia como resultado, y en este contexto, la palabra determinista significa
que el resultado de realizar
la operación depende completamente del estado clásico en el que se encontraba el sistema
antes de que se realizara la operación.
En otras palabras, no hay
ningún elemento de azar cuando se realiza una operación
determinista, por lo que no hay aleatoriedad
ni incertidumbre involucradas.
En términos matemáticos, las operaciones deterministas
se describen mediante funciones.
Toda función f de la forma
que ves aquí, lo que significa que tanto la entrada como la salida de la función
corresponden a elementos de
nuestro conjunto de estados clásicos sigma, describe una operación determinista.
El estado clásico a se
transforma en el estado f de a para cada elección de un estado a.
Para toda función f de esta forma, siempre habrá una matriz M única que satisface esta condición
que ves aquí,
y es que al multiplicar
M por el vector ket a obtenemos el vector ket f de a,
y eso es válido para cada
elección de un estado clásico a.
No es muy difícil escribir
una descripción explícita de M dada cualquier función f
de esta forma que hayamos elegido.
Siempre tendrá exactamente
un uno en cada columna y todos los demás elementos serán iguales a cero.
Y aquí está la fórmula. La entrada b, a de M es igual a uno si b es igual a f de a
y en caso contrario es igual a cero, y con esto queremos decir
que esta es la entrada de M cuya fila corresponde a b
y cuya columna corresponde a a.
Veremos algunos ejemplos en un momento y entenderemos por qué funciona esta fórmula.
Ahora bien, puede que no quede claro por qué querríamos tomar una función y expresarla como una matriz así,
pero tiene sentido hacerlo. Una de las razones, y quizás sea la razón principal, es que si tenemos un sistema
en un estado probabilístico
y realizamos una operación determinista
sobre ese sistema, entonces el estado probabilístico resultante se puede obtener
mediante la multiplicación de matriz por vector, es decir, si nuestro sistema está
en un estado probabilístico
que está representado por
algún vector de probabilidad v y realizamos la operación determinista descrita por M
sobre ese sistema, entonces el estado probabilístico resultante estará dado por M multiplicado por v.
Por cierto, esta flecha con una pequeña
barra así es simplemente una notación común en matemáticas para indicar cómo una
cosa se mapea o se transforma en otra. Podrías usar una flecha ordinaria, pero esto es convencional
y es reconocible, y quizás es un poco más específico que una simple flecha, que puede significar muchas cosas distintas.
Ahora veamos un ejemplo o, en realidad, una colección de ejemplos.
Consideremos qué ocurre cuando tomamos nuestro conjunto de estados clásicos sigma como el alfabeto binario, una vez más.
No hay demasiadas funciones distintas de la forma que hemos estado discutiendo cuando este es nuestro conjunto de estados clásicos y, para ser más precisos, hay exactamente cuatro
funciones de esta forma.
Aquí, esas cuatro funciones están descritas por sus llamadas tablas de valores.
La primera tabla describe
la primera función, que hemos llamado f1.
Para cada posible entrada a la izquierda, listamos la salida correspondiente
a la derecha, así que f1 de cero es igual a cero,
y f1 de uno es, también, igual a cero, es decir, f1 es
la función constante cero.
Siempre toma el valor cero.
La segunda función f2
es la función identidad.
La salida siempre es igual a la entrada, como puedes ver en la segunda tabla.
La tercera función f3 está
descrita por la tercera tabla.
f3 de cero es igual a uno, y f3 de uno es igual a cero.
Esta función es mejor
conocida como la función NOT o negación lógica.
A veces también la llamamos inversión de bit, porque convierte cero
en uno y uno en cero.
La última función f4 es,
de nuevo, una función constante igual que la primera, pero esta es la función constante uno
porque siempre toma el valor uno.
Y esas son las únicas cuatro funciones del alfabeto binario a sí mismo.
Aquí están las cuatro matrices que corresponden a estas cuatro funciones, descritas por
la fórmula de antes,
que puedes ver justo aquí, y si te apetece, puedes pausar el video y comprobarlo.
Recuerda que con las matrices, el orden de los índices es siempre filas primero, columna después.
Así que la entrada b, a corresponde
a la fila b y la columna a, o la fila que corresponde
al estado clásico b
y la columna que corresponde
al estado clásico a.
Por ejemplo, si miramos
la primera función, tenemos que f1 de cero es igual a cero
y, correspondientemente, la
entrada cero, cero de M1 es igual a uno.
La entrada uno, cero
que está justo aquí es igual a cero, y puedes hacer lo mismo para el caso
en que la entrada es igual a uno y, de manera similar, para las
otras tres funciones.
También puedes verificar que esta
fórmula de antes es verdadera y puedes ir una a una por todas las diferentes
posibilidades para comprobarlo.
Y de hecho, si piensas en cómo funciona
la multiplicación de matrices, realmente puedes intuirlo a simple vista.
Cuando multiplicas una matriz por un vector de la base estándar como este, puedes imaginar que
estás tomando la entrada
y metiéndola en la
parte superior de una de las matrices, en la columna que corresponde
al estado clásico
dentro del ket, y la salida que
obtienes es simplemente esa columna como vector de probabilidad.
Por ejemplo, M3 multiplicado por ket
cero te da cero, uno
como vector de probabilidad, que es ket uno.
M3 multiplicado por ket
uno te da uno, cero, que es ket cero, y así sucesivamente.
Hablaremos de las operaciones sobre
estados probabilísticos más en un momento, pero primero, introduzcamos la segunda parte de la notación de Dirac.
Esto va a ser útil
para hablar de operaciones y pensarlas como matrices C, y también va a ser una herramienta estándar
que seguiremos usando de aquí en adelante. La configuración es igual que antes.
Tenemos cualquier conjunto de estados clásicos sigma con el que estemos trabajando y suponemos que tenemos alguna forma de
ordenar esos estados clásicos.
Entonces escribimos esta cosa
que ves justo aquí, donde esta vez la
barra angular está a la izquierda en lugar de a la derecha, para representar
el vector fila que tiene un uno
en la entrada que
corresponde a a y un cero en todas las demás entradas correspondientes a todos los
demás estados clásicos.
Así que la diferencia entre
esta cosa y ket a es que esta es un vector fila y
ket a es un vector columna,
pero por lo demás, los vectores
están definidos de manera similar.
A esto lo leemos como bra a; no sé si se supone que tiene gracia, pero la idea es que los nombres bra y ket
son las dos mitades de la palabra bracket, y tendremos más que decir
sobre eso en un momento.
Pero primero, veamos
un ejemplo muy rápido.
Para el alfabeto binario, tenemos que bra cero es
este vector fila de aquí, análogo a ket a,
excepto que es un vector fila
en lugar de un vector columna, y bra uno es este vector de aquí.
Ahora bien, en general, si multiplicamos un vector
fila por un vector columna, pensando en estos simplemente como matrices
que resultan tener solo
una fila o solo una columna, obtenemos una matriz de uno por uno, que podemos interpretar
como un escalar.
Por cierto, aquí deberías
pensar en estos asteriscos como representando números arbitrarios.
En particular, si
multiplicamos el vector fila bra a por el vector columna ket b,
entonces hay dos cosas que pueden ocurrir.
Una es que a y b sean iguales, es decir, que sean el mismo estado clásico, en cuyo caso los unos se alinearán
y el producto será igual a uno; o podría darse el caso
de que a y b sean distintos,
por lo que los unos no se alinean y el producto es igual a cero.
Una forma sencilla de expresar
estas observaciones es como se muestra aquí.
Y solo para mantener el orden, escribimos este producto así, con una sola barra en el medio, y significa exactamente lo mismo
que esto de aquí.
Y ahora puedes ver cómo el
bra y el ket se unen para formar un bracket, que también
se denomina producto interno,
y eso es algo
bastante importante a lo que volveremos
en la lección número tres.
Multiplicar un vector
columna por un vector fila, por otra parte, nos da una matriz como puedes ver aquí.
Así que, por ejemplo, volviendo
de nuevo al alfabeto binario, si multiplicamos ket cero por bra cero,
lo que obtenemos es esta matriz de aquí, y podemos revisar
las demás posibilidades para ver qué ocurre.
Ket cero por bra uno nos da
esta matriz de aquí, donde el uno se ha desplazado
a esta posición.
Ket uno, bra cero tiene este aspecto, y aquí está ket uno, bra uno.
Lo que vemos que ocurre es que hay un único uno en una matriz que de lo demás es todo ceros, y la posición de ese uno
viene determinada por los
estados clásicos que elegimos en el bra y en el ket.
Más precisamente, y
esto es cierto en general, para cualquier elección de un conjunto de estados clásicos, la matriz que obtenemos al
multiplicar ket a por bra b
es la matriz con un uno en la entrada a, b y un cero en todas las demás entradas.
Y ahora que tenemos tanto la
primera como la segunda parte de la notación de Dirac, disponemos de una herramienta muy útil para conectar operaciones con matrices.
Así que volvamos brevemente
a las operaciones deterministas y recordemos que un poco
antes en la lección,
se estableció que para toda función f de
esta forma aquí, tenemos una operación determinista que transforma a en f de a
para cada posible estado clásico a. Y dijimos que para
cualquier función como esta, siempre existe una
matriz M única que actúa así
sobre los estados de la base estándar.
Usando la notación de Dirac, ahora podemos expresar esta matriz de forma muy sencilla, como ves aquí,
y podemos ver cómo a veces
es posible trabajar con matrices completamente
dentro del marco de la notación de Dirac
sin necesidad de convertir
explícitamente a vectores y matrices, es decir, rectángulos rellenos de números.
En este caso, podemos comprobar que la
fórmula requerida es cierta multiplicando M por ket a.
Sustituimos nuestra
expresión para M de esta forma y podemos eliminar los paréntesis y unir el bra
b con el ket a así.
Y eso es porque la
multiplicación de matrices es lineal, en este caso en el primer argumento, y es asociativa, así que podemos eliminar los paréntesis.
Y ahora, recordando que tenemos un a fijo del que hablamos mientras sumamos sobre todas las
posibles elecciones de b,
este bracket de aquí siempre
va a ser igual a cero cuando b no es igual a a, por lo que no habrá ninguna
contribución a la suma,
y cuando b es igual a a, el bracket será igual a uno y nos quedará
este único término de aquí.
Esa es la fórmula que queríamos, y así tenemos una forma muy elegante y sencilla de expresar una función como una matriz.
Además de las operaciones deterministas, también tenemos operaciones que
por sí mismas introducen aleatoriedad o incertidumbre sobre el
estado clásico de un sistema.
Usamos el término operación probabilista para referirnos a operaciones como esta, y, para ser precisos, cuando decimos operación probabilista,
nos referimos a operaciones que
podrían introducir aleatoriedad, por lo que las operaciones deterministas son en realidad un caso especial
de las operaciones probabilistas
que simplemente no llegan a
introducir ninguna aleatoriedad.
Aquí hay un ejemplo sencillo en el que
se introduce algo de aleatoriedad.
Esta es una operación sobre un único bit. La forma en que funciona es que si el estado clásico
del bit es cero,
no ocurre nada. El bit permanece como cero, pero si el estado clásico
del bit es uno, la operación cambia el bit a cero
con probabilidad igual a 1/2.
No hay un nombre especial
para esta operación, al menos que yo sepa.
Es solo un ejemplo, pero podrías imaginar realizar
esta operación sobre un bit.
Al igual que las operaciones deterministas, las operaciones probabilísticas se pueden
representar mediante matrices y su acción sobre estados probabilísticos
viene dada por la multiplicación matriz-vector, igual que antes.
En este caso, no necesariamente ocurre que las matrices tengan exactamente un uno en cada columna y ceros en el resto.
Las operaciones probabilísticas están
representadas de forma más general por matrices estocásticas.
Estas son matrices cuyos elementos son todos
números reales no negativos y donde los elementos de
cada columna suman uno.
Eso equivale a decir
que las matrices estocásticas son matrices donde cada columna
forma un vector de probabilidad.
Tiene sentido cuando piensas en
la acción de una matriz sobre un vector de base estándar.
Consideras cualquier
estado clásico que quieras e imaginas que introduces ese estado por arriba de la matriz en la columna que corresponde
a ese estado clásico,
y esa columna te dice cuál es
el estado probabilístico que resulta como un vector de probabilidad.
La operación probabilística
de nuestro ejemplo, por ejemplo, está descrita por esta matriz de aquí.
Si aplicamos esta operación
al estado clásico cero, el estado probabilístico que obtenemos viene dado por la primera columna,
que es, de nuevo, el estado clásico cero o, equivalentemente, el estado probabilístico
en el que el cero ocurre con probabilidad uno.
Si en cambio aplicamos esta operación al estado clásico uno, entonces efectivamente solo aleatorizamos el bit y, en consecuencia, obtenemos
este vector de probabilidad de aquí
donde la probabilidad de
cada uno de los estados posibles es igual a 1/2.
En general, si aplicamos esta operación a cualquier estado probabilístico, el efecto es esencialmente
solo un promedio ponderado entre las dos columnas
porque así es como funciona la
multiplicación matriz-vector.
Es lineal, así que simplemente promediamos los dos
resultados posibles en consecuencia.
Cuando pensamos en las operaciones probabilísticas
de esta manera, es natural pensar en
ellas como algo que potencialmente introduce o inyecta aleatoriedad.
Podemos leer las columnas una a una y ver la aleatoriedad
que introducen para cada posible estado clásico.
También puedes pensar en
las operaciones probabilísticas de una manera ligeramente distinta: que son elecciones aleatorias de operaciones deterministas.
Por ejemplo, en nuestro caso, podemos pensar en esta operación como equivalente a
lanzar una moneda al aire
y ejecutar o bien la
función constante cero o bien la función identidad,
cada una con probabilidad 1/2,
y puedes ver eso reflejado
aquí mismo en esta ecuación.
Eso siempre es posible para
cualquier operación probabilística, y es bastante intuitivo.
Si tomaste decisiones aleatorias
como parte de algún proceso, siempre podrías imaginarte tomando esas decisiones aleatorias de antemano
y luego codificando en duro esas
elecciones en alguna colección de operaciones deterministas.
A veces es bastante útil pensar en las operaciones probabilísticas
de esta manera, y veremos un ejemplo
de esto más adelante en un par de lecciones.
Lo último que hay que decir
sobre la información clásica en esta lección tiene que ver con la composición
de operaciones probabilísticas, que simplemente significa ejecutar
una detrás de otra.
Supongamos que
tenemos un sistema llamado X y que M1 hasta Mn son matrices estocásticas que representan operaciones probabilísticas
sobre X.
Imagina primero que tenemos
un vector de probabilidad v, que representa un estado probabilístico
de X en algún momento, y luego aplicamos primero
la primera operación probabilística a X, representada por la matriz M1, y luego aplicamos la segunda
operación probabilística,
que está representada por M2.
Si hacemos eso, entonces el
vector de probabilidad que obtenemos tras aplicar solo la primera
operación es M1 por v,
y luego cuando aplicamos
la segunda operación, el vector de probabilidad resultante es M2 multiplicado por el vector que obtuvimos
tras aplicar M1. Así que queda así.
Ahora bien, la multiplicación de matrices
es una operación asociativa, lo que significa que no importa dónde pongamos estos paréntesis.
Así que podríamos poner los paréntesis
fácilmente de esta otra manera.
Es muy simple, pero también es interesante porque revela que podemos
pensar en la operación de aplicar primero M1
y luego aplicar M2
como una sola operación.
En otras palabras, la
operación probabilística que obtenemos al componer la primera y la
segunda operación probabilística está representada por el
producto matricial M2 por M1,
y esa es la misma operación independientemente de cuál fuera el estado probabilístico
con el que empezamos.
No necesitamos saber nada sobre el vector de probabilidad v para pensar o para describir
esta operación compuesta.
Observa que el orden
aquí es M2 a la izquierda y M1 a la derecha, lo cual se debe a que la
matriz de la derecha, M1,
es la que se
multiplica por el vector v, mientras que M2 se multiplica
por el vector que obtenemos tras multiplicar por M1.
Así que siempre hay que tener en cuenta que el orden en cierto
sentido se invierte.
La operación que se realiza
primero es la que está a la derecha y la operación que se realiza al final, o en este caso, segunda,
es la que está a la izquierda.
Si no nos detenemos en la segunda operación y las aplicamos todas en
orden empezando por la primera y terminando por la última, que es Mn,
entonces la composición de todas
estas operaciones juntas viene dada por este producto
que ves aquí mismo,
y ves que el orden
una vez más está invertido exactamente por la misma razón que antes.
En resumen, las composiciones
de operaciones probabilísticas se representan mediante productos
de matrices estocásticas que las representan.
Teniendo en cuenta que este es
el orden de las matrices en el producto.
Siempre obtendrás una matriz estocástica al tomar un producto de
matrices estocásticas como esta, y a veces expresamos este hecho
diciendo que las matrices
estocásticas son cerradas bajo la multiplicación, y la forma en que
puedes pensar en esto es que no puedes salir del
conjunto de matrices estocásticas
multiplicándolas porque el conjunto es cerrado.
Volviendo al
orden de las matrices en este producto, es importante notar que el
orden realmente importa.
La multiplicación de matrices no es conmutativa. Si cambias el orden de
las matrices en el producto, podrías cambiar el resultado,
y no necesitamos ir más lejos que las operaciones
deterministas para ver esto.
Aquí hay un ejemplo simple de
dos matrices estocásticas, ambas de las cuales representan
operaciones deterministas donde el orden importa.
M1 representa la función constante cero. Suponiendo que imaginamos que estas dos operaciones actúan sobre bits, igual que en el ejemplo de antes.
M2 representa la operación
not o un volteo de bit.
Si realizas M1 primero
y luego realizas M2, el resultado es esta matriz aquí, que representa la
función constante uno.
Si pones un bit en cero
y luego lo volteas, es lo mismo que simplemente
poner ese bit en uno.
Por otro lado, si realizas M2 primero
y luego realizas M1, este es el resultado aquí,
y esto tiene sentido porque si volteas un bit
y luego lo pones en cero, es lo mismo que
simplemente ponerlo en cero.
No importó que lo hayas volteado. Obviamente, estas dos
matrices no son iguales, y así tenemos un
ejemplo muy simple que revela
que el orden sí importa. Por supuesto, esto no es sorprendente en absoluto.
Todos sabemos que el orden en que
se realizan las operaciones importa, o al menos, puede importar.
Por ejemplo, si enciendes un
fósforo y luego soplas sobre él, el resultado es muy diferente
de soplar primero sobre el fósforo
y luego encenderlo. En este punto, hemos hablado bastante
sobre información clásica y ahora por fin es el momento de
hablar sobre información cuántica.
Y lo que encontraremos es que
matemáticamente hablando, la información cuántica funciona
de una manera muy similar a la información clásica
con algunas diferencias clave.
La primera diferencia clave
está justo al inicio: cómo definimos un estado, en este caso, un estado cuántico de un sistema,
y hay un sentido en el que esta única elección de cómo
definimos un estado cuántico determina en gran medida cómo
funciona la información cuántica.
También definiremos cómo
funcionan las mediciones y las operaciones, y en la próxima lección hablaremos de cómo
funciona la información cuántica no solo para sistemas individuales
sino para múltiples sistemas,
pero estas cosas en realidad
se deducen de forma bastante natural una vez que se ha establecido la noción de estado cuántico de un sistema individual de
forma aislada.
Aquí está la definición. Un estado cuántico de un sistema se representa mediante un vector columna cuyos índices están puestos
en correspondencia con los
estados clásicos de ese sistema.
Así que aquí asumimos que
el sistema del que hablamos tiene algún conjunto de estados clásicos, igual que cuando hablamos
de información clásica
y estados probabilísticos. Las entradas en un vector de estado cuántico
son números complejos, en oposición al caso probabilístico
donde las entradas son
números reales no negativos.
Y esta vez, la suma de los valores absolutos al
cuadrado de las entradas debe ser igual a uno, en oposición a que la suma sea igual a uno
como tenemos en el caso probabilístico.
Los números complejos que aparecen
en un vector de estado cuántico se llaman a veces amplitudes y desempeñan un papel
similar al de las probabilidades,
pero no son probabilidades y no tienen la
misma interpretación.
Ahora bien, no puedo darte una buena razón de por qué los estados cuánticos
deberían definirse así, salvo decir que los
físicos han descubierto
que esta definición
es físicamente relevante y nos permite describir y modelar
sistemas mecánico-cuánticos.
En otras palabras, elegimos esta definición
porque funciona, no porque haya
razones particulares por las que los estados cuánticos deban
definirse así.
Con respecto a la
matemática de esta noción de estado cuántico, el primer paso para comprenderla y trabajar con ella es
recordar esta definición
de la norma euclidiana de un vector, que puedes pensar geométricamente como la longitud de un vector, igual que pensarías en la longitud
de un vector real bidimensional si lo dibujaras en una hoja
de papel como una flecha que parte del origen de la manera habitual.
Concretamente, si tenemos un
vector columna v como este, que asumimos que tiene
entradas de números complejos, alpha uno hasta alpha n,
entonces la norma euclidiana de v se define como ves aquí mismo.
Esta es la notación que
usamos para la norma euclidiana, colocando estas barras dobles alrededor del vector del que estamos hablando.
En este caso es v, y la forma en que se define la norma euclidiana es que es la raíz cuadrada de la suma
de los valores absolutos al cuadrado
de las entradas del vector.
Así que otra forma de definir
qué es un vector de estado cuántico es que un vector de estado cuántico es un vector columna cuyos
entradas son números complejos cuya norma euclídea es igual a uno, lo que significa que es un vector unitario respecto a la norma euclídea.
Esto se debe a que la suma de
los valores absolutos al cuadrado es igual a uno si y solo si la norma
euclídea es igual a uno.
La raíz cuadrada no cambia nada cuando la suma de los
valores absolutos al cuadrado es igual a uno.
Entonces, eso es lo que es un vector de estado cuántico. Es un vector columna con índices que corresponden a los
estados clásicos de un sistema
que tiene entradas de números complejos y norma euclídea igual a uno.
Lo que eso significa, lo que implica o cómo debemos interpretar esta
noción es otra cuestión y, en cierto sentido,
el estudio de la información
y la computación cuántica es una exploración de lo que
esta definición implica, al menos en términos de
procesamiento de información.
Este es simplemente el punto de partida.
Como nota aparte, déjame mencionar que existen
otras llamadas normas además de la norma euclídea, y esta notación aquí
con las barras dobles
alrededor de un vector no siempre
significa la norma euclídea.
En diferentes contextos, esta notación puede referirse
a una norma diferente.
Por ejemplo, la suma
de los valores absolutos sin cuadrados ni raíz
cuadrada es una norma diferente,
que a menudo se llama la norma uno. De hecho, hay bastantes
normas diferentes.
A veces verás
que esta notación se usa con un subíndice después del
segundo par de barras que da más información sobre de qué norma hablamos.
Y cuando hacemos eso, es bastante típico que el número dos como subíndice
signifique la norma euclídea.
Pero en esta serie, siempre que tengamos un
vector columna como este, esta notación de doble barra por sí sola
significa la norma euclídea.
Aquí hay algunos ejemplos
de vectores de estado cuántico, y estos vectores de estado cuántico en particular son vectores de estado de qubit,
lo que significa que los
estados clásicos de nuestro sistema son cero y uno.
La palabra qubit es una abreviación de bit cuántico, que básicamente es un bit
que puede estar en un estado cuántico.
Los dos primeros ejemplos son muy simples. Los vectores de base estándar
ket cero y ket uno son vectores de estado cuántico.
Ambos son vectores columna, y los índices corresponden
a los estados clásicos cero y uno, y las entradas de estos
vectores son números complejos.
Para estos vectores en particular, las entradas son cero y uno, que son números reales y, de hecho, son enteros, pero también son números complejos
que resultan tener
la parte imaginaria igual a cero.
Cada vector tiene una entrada igual a uno y una entrada igual a cero.
Entonces, cuando sumamos los valores absolutos
al cuadrado de las entradas, obtenemos uno en ambos casos.
Así que las condiciones
requeridas para que estos vectores sean vectores de estado cuántico se cumplen.
Los dos ejemplos siguientes son estados de qubit muy comunes llamados el estado más y el estado menos.
Se denotan como
ves aquí en la pantalla, ya sea con un ket más
o un ket menos así, y se definen como
puedes ver justo aquí.
De nuevo, las entradas de estos
vectores son números complejos. Esta vez, son uno positivo sobre la raíz cuadrada de dos o uno negativo sobre la raíz cuadrada de dos,
y cuando sumamos los
valores absolutos al cuadrado, obtenemos 1/2 más 1/2, que es uno.
Por cierto, poner un
signo más o un signo menos dentro de un ket así
puede parecer un poco extraño, porque estos no son estados clásicos
de nuestro sistema,
pero esta notación se usa de todos modos, y volveremos a esto en un momento.
Pero por ahora, en resumen, podemos usar la notación de Dirac para poner el nombre que queramos para un vector dentro de un ket.
El vector no tiene que
ser un vector de base estándar cuando usamos la notación de Dirac.
Aquí hay un ejemplo final de estado de qubit
por el momento, de todas formas.
Es un vector de estado cuántico de un qubit que no tiene un nombre especial y que no es particularmente significativo.
Las entradas de este vector son uno más dos veces i
sobre tres y menos 2/3.
Estos son números complejos, y si calculas los
valores absolutos al cuadrado de estas dos entradas, obtendrás 5/9 para la primera
y 4/9 para la segunda. Entonces, la suma de los valores absolutos
al cuadrado es igual a uno.
Y aquí hay un último ejemplo. Esta vez para un sistema
cuyos estados clásicos son los cuatro palos de la baraja.
No sé por qué tendríamos un sistema cuyos estados clásicos
son los cuatro palos de la baraja en un estado cuántico, pero es posible en principio
y es solo como ejemplo.
Las entradas correspondientes
a los diferentes palos son 1/2 para tréboles, i
negativo sobre dos para diamantes,
cero para corazones porque no aparece en la suma y uno sobre la raíz
cuadrada de dos para picas.
Y así es como se
ve como vector columna, asumiendo que hemos ordenado
los estados clásicos como lo hicimos antes,
que es el orden que
ves justo aquí.
Tomar el valor absoluto
al cuadrado de estas entradas da un cuarto para la primera, y también un cuarto para la siguiente.
El valor absoluto al cuadrado
de cero es igual a cero, así que esa entrada no
contribuye a la suma.
Y finalmente, para la última, obtenemos 1/2. Entonces la suma es igual a uno, como se requiere para que este vector
sea un vector de estado cuántico.
Hace un momento, usamos la notación
ket más y ket menos para referirnos a dos vectores de estado de qubit que no son vectores de base estándar.
Y me gustaría volver
a este punto brevemente y explicar cómo se usa la notación de Dirac para vectores arbitrarios y no solo para vectores de base estándar.
Como ya mencioné, podemos usar el nombre que
queramos dentro de un bra o ket para referirnos a un vector.
Los kets son vectores columna
y los bras son vectores fila, igual que antes.
Como ejemplo, la letra griega
psi se usa muy comúnmente dentro de un ket para referirse a algún vector arbitrario,
y aquí la usamos para
darle un nombre al vector de estado de antes que no
tiene un nombre especial.
Cuando hacemos esto, el ket psi no
necesariamente tiene ningún significado por sí solo.
Es solo el nombre de un vector, y está dentro de un ket para ayudarnos a aclarar
que es un vector columna.
Esto puede resultar
un poco confuso a veces, y existe la posibilidad de ambigüedad si la letra psi pudiera asociarse
con un estado clásico de
algún sistema, por ejemplo, pero en general no
genera ningún problema, y no tienes que usar
la notación de Dirac así
si no quieres. Usar una letra minúscula como
u, v o w sin un ket también es una forma válida de
denotar un vector columna
o, más específicamente,
un vector de estado cuántico.
Tú eliges qué notación
usas para expresarte.
Solo necesitas asegurarte
de que, en primer lugar, el significado de lo que
intentas expresar sea claro para los demás.
Y en segundo lugar, que entiendas lo que
los demás intentan expresar, incluso cuando sus preferencias de notación no son iguales a las tuyas.
Hay una regla muy importante para usar la notación de Dirac
con vectores arbitrarios, y es que si
tienes un vector columna
que has decidido escribir
como ket psi, por ejemplo, o podría ser un nombre distinto
dentro de un ket, entonces el vector fila bra psi
se entiende como
la transpuesta conjugada del vector ket psi.
Y aquí esto se escribe como una ecuación donde este símbolo dagger se refiere a la transpuesta conjugada.
Lo que eso es específicamente es
el vector fila que obtienes haciendo, en primer lugar, la transpuesta del vector, es decir, girar
el vector de lado y convertirlo de columna en fila
sin cambiar las entradas. Y en segundo lugar, tomar el conjugado complejo
de cada una de las entradas.
En realidad puedes realizar
esas dos operaciones —la transpuesta y el
conjugado complejo entrada por entrada— en cualquier orden, ya que
esas dos operaciones conmutan.
Entonces, para el vector de este ejemplo, dado que hemos decidido
llamar a este vector ket psi, se entiende que bra psi
significa este vector de aquí
donde hemos transpuesto el vector convirtiendo ket cero y ket
uno en bra cero y bra uno, y hemos tomado el conjugado
complejo de cada entrada,
por eso uno más
dos veces i sobre tres se convierte en uno menos dos
veces i sobre tres aquí.
Así es como se ven estos vectores cuando se escriben
explícitamente como un vector columna y un vector fila.
Nota, por cierto, que
esta regla es consistente con la notación que usamos cuando tenemos estados clásicos
dentro del bra y el ket.
En ese caso, las entradas son
todas cero excepto por un uno, así que tomar el conjugado
complejo no cambia nada en ese caso.
Ahora hemos visto cómo los estados cuánticos se representan como vectores, pero no queda claro en este
momento qué significa o qué implicaciones tiene
en términos de lo que
puedes hacer con el sistema en un estado cuántico o cómo puedes interactuar con él.
Lo primero que necesitamos hacer para aclarar estos temas
es hablar sobre las mediciones.
De forma intuitiva,
las mediciones proporcionan un mecanismo para extraer información
clásica de los sistemas cuánticos.
Cuando observamos un sistema
en un estado cuántico, no vemos un estado cuántico, igual que no vemos
estados probabilísticos,
vemos estados clásicos, y esta noción de medición es lo que proporciona la interfaz.
Si nosotros, como humanos, queremos saber algo sobre un sistema cuántico, tenemos que medirlo, y al hacerlo, extraeremos información clásica
sobre el estado cuántico
en el que se encontraba ese sistema.
Existen distintas
nociones de medición. La diferencia es realmente de
generalidad, y vamos a empezar con la más simple y básica,
que típicamente se llama una
medición en base estándar.
Generalizaremos esto
en lecciones posteriores. Hablaremos sobre las llamadas
mediciones proyectivas en la lección tres, y más adelante en la
tercera unidad de la serie,
hablaremos sobre las mediciones generales, que también se llaman medidas de
operador con valor positivo, o POVMs por sus siglas en inglés.
Pero por ahora, limitaremos nuestra atención a las mediciones en base estándar.
Cuando se realiza una medición
sobre un sistema, habrá algún conjunto
de posibles resultados de esa medición, que son resultados clásicos,
y en el caso de una
medición en base estándar, esos posibles resultados son
precisamente los estados clásicos del sistema que se está midiendo.
Cada uno de esos estados clásicos será el resultado de la medición con cierta probabilidad, y esa probabilidad es
el valor absoluto al cuadrado
de la entrada correspondiente
a ese estado clásico, del vector de estado cuántico
en el que se encontraba el sistema justo antes de ser medido.
Sabemos que el valor absoluto al cuadrado de cualquier número complejo es un número real no negativo, y sabemos por la definición
de los vectores de estado cuántico
que la suma de los valores absolutos
al cuadrado de las entradas de un vector de estado cuántico es igual a uno.
Así que esto tiene sentido. Cada estado clásico aparecerá como el resultado de la
medición con cierta probabilidad, y las probabilidades suman uno.
Aquí hay algunos ejemplos. Primero, supongamos que tenemos un
qubit en el estado más.
Si medimos este qubit con respecto a una medición en la
base estándar, obtenemos un cero o
un uno como resultado.
La probabilidad de obtener un cero es el valor absoluto
al cuadrado de uno sobre raíz de dos, que es 1/2, y esa es la misma
probabilidad de obtener un uno.
Entonces, si mides un estado más, obtendrás un bit aleatorio uniforme.
Si el sistema está en un estado
menos en lugar de un estado más, entonces medir funciona exactamente de
la misma manera.
Las probabilidades son, de nuevo, 1/2 para cada resultado posible.
La única diferencia aquí es que el signo más se convirtió en un signo menos, pero cuando tomamos el valor
absoluto, nada cambia.
Si medimos este estado qubit, la probabilidad de obtener el resultado cero es el valor absoluto al cuadrado de uno más dos por i
sobre tres, que es 5/9,
y la probabilidad de obtener el resultado uno es el valor absoluto al cuadrado
de menos 2/3, que es 4/9.
Y finalmente, al medir
el estado de la base estándar, el ket cero da el resultado
cero con certeza, y de igual forma, medir el estado ket uno
produce el resultado uno con certeza. Eso es porque el valor
absoluto al cuadrado de uno es uno.
Similar a lo que teníamos en
el contexto probabilístico. Podemos asociar estos estados
cuánticos, ket cero y ket uno, con que el sistema se encuentra en
esos estados clásicos,
y este ejemplo es consistente
con esa interpretación.
Ahora bien, igual que en
el contexto probabilístico, si medimos un sistema cuando
se encuentra en un estado cuántico,
el estado cambiará, en general, como resultado de haber
realizado esa medición.
En particular, y de nuevo, esto es exactamente igual a lo que teníamos
en el contexto probabilístico.
Si medimos un sistema y el resultado de la medición
es el estado clásico a, entonces el nuevo estado cuántico
del sistema se convierte en ket a.
Entonces, para este estado de aquí,
por ejemplo, vemos el mismo tipo
de comportamiento que teníamos en el contexto probabilístico.
Si medimos, entonces con probabilidad 5/9, obtenemos el resultado cero, en cuyo caso, el estado
transiciona a ket cero,
y con probabilidad
4/9, el resultado es uno, y el estado transiciona a ket uno.
A veces este fenómeno se denomina colapso
del estado cuántico, y es el tipo de
cosa que mantiene despierta a la gente
que estudia los fundamentos
de la mecánica cuántica.
Pero desde una perspectiva puramente
matemática, es realmente bastante sencillo
y muy análogo a lo que tenemos en el caso probabilístico.
La fuente de tensión aquí, en cierto sentido, tiene que ver con la naturaleza fundamental
de los estados cuánticos y lo que representan
y cómo se diferencian
de los estados probabilísticos. Pero a nivel matemático, esto es quizás lo que cabría esperar.
Fíjate, por cierto, que si
midieras una segunda vez, obtendrías exactamente
el mismo resultado que en la primera medición.
Entonces hay un límite en cuánta
información clásica puede extraerse de un estado cuántico, y volveremos a este punto pronto
en otra lección. Hemos hablado de los estados cuánticos así como de las mediciones, específicamente las mediciones en la base estándar,
que proporcionan una manera de
extraer información clásica de los estados cuánticos.
El tema restante de
esta lección son las operaciones, específicamente las operaciones unitarias, que describen cómo
los estados cuánticos de los sistemas
pueden cambiar. Naturalmente, dado que los
vectores de estado cuántico son diferentes de los vectores de probabilidad, esperarías que el conjunto
de operaciones permitidas
sobre los estados cuánticos sea diferente de lo que tenemos para
la información clásica, y en efecto, así es.
Mientras que las operaciones sobre los estados probabilísticos están representadas por matrices estocásticas, las operaciones sobre los vectores de estado cuántico
están representadas por matrices unitarias.
Aquí está la definición de las matrices unitarias.
Una matriz cuadrada U con
entradas de números complejos es unitaria si satisface las igualdades
que ves aquí.
El símbolo dagger representa
la transpuesta conjugada, que ya vimos para los vectores cuando hablamos de la notación de Dirac
hace unos momentos.
Aquí estamos aplicando la
transpuesta conjugada a una matriz en lugar de a un vector, pero es esencialmente lo mismo.
Transponemos la matriz, lo que simplemente significa que
intercambiamos filas y columnas, así que la entrada JK se convierte en la entrada KJ,
y también tomamos el conjugado
complejo de cada entrada.
Además, esta notación de aquí
significa la matriz identidad.
Estas dos igualdades de aquí
son en realidad equivalentes. Si tienes una, entonces
automáticamente tienes la otra.
Ambas son equivalentes a
decir que U es invertible, y que la inversa es igual
a la transpuesta conjugada.
Eso solo es válido para matrices
cuadradas, por cierto. Si tienes una matriz que no es cuadrada, entonces una de esas dos
igualdades puede ser cierta,
pero la otra no lo será.
Pero aquí estamos hablando
de matrices cuadradas.
Esta es la definición
estándar de las matrices unitarias, y es conveniente porque es fácil verificar
si una matriz es unitaria.
Solo multiplicas la matriz por su transpuesta conjugada en cualquier lado, y ves si obtienes
la matriz identidad.
Hay una forma equivalente de caracterizar las matrices unitarias, y es que una
matriz cuadrada es unitaria si y solo si nunca
cambia la norma euclidiana
de ningún vector al multiplicar. Una matriz N por N U es unitaria si y solo si la
norma euclidiana de U por v
es igual a la norma euclidiana de v para todo vector columna v de dimensión n con entradas de números complejos.
Por lo tanto, si v es
un vector de estado cuántico, entonces U por v también es
un vector de estado cuántico, porque los vectores de estado cuántico
son simplemente los vectores que tienen
norma euclidiana igual a uno.
De hecho, podemos decir un poco más: las matrices unitarias son precisamente las matrices que siempre transforman
vectores de estado cuántico
en vectores de estado cuántico. Es una situación similar a la que tenemos con las matrices estocásticas
y los vectores de probabilidad.
Las matrices estocásticas
son precisamente las matrices que siempre transforman vectores de probabilidad en vectores de probabilidad.
Así que una vez que decidimos que las operaciones deben representarse mediante matrices, lo cual equivale a decir que las transformaciones actúan linealmente
sobre los vectores que representan estados, estas elecciones para los conjuntos
de operaciones permitidas se derivan de forma natural, al menos
en un sentido matemático.
Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos de operaciones unitarias sobre qubits.
Veremos muchos más ejemplos
de operaciones unitarias en lecciones posteriores, incluyendo operaciones unitarias en sistemas
con más de dos estados clásicos. Pero por ahora, nos centraremos solo
en las operaciones unitarias sobre qubits.
Vamos a ver estos
ejemplos particulares una y otra vez, así que definitivamente vale la pena
familiarizarse con estas operaciones.
La primera colección de ejemplos son las llamadas operaciones de Pauli.
Estas son las operaciones que corresponden a las matrices de Pauli, que se muestran aquí.
Todas son unitarias, y puedes comprobarlo para cada una según la definición anterior.
Estas matrices en particular
resultan ser iguales a sus propias transpuestas conjugadas, lo que significa que son
todas matrices hermitianas.
Así que verificar que todas
son unitarias, en este caso, es cuestión de elevar al cuadrado cada una y ver que el resultado
es la matriz identidad.
Los nombres que ves para estas
matrices son bastante estándar, y también verás sigma
x, sigma y y sigma z llamadas simplemente X, Y y Z.
Ten en cuenta, sin embargo, que las
letras mayúsculas X, Y y Z también se usan comúnmente para otros fines, incluso en el contexto de
la información cuántica,
pero son nombres muy comunes
para estas matrices.
La operación sigma x, o X,
también se llama inversión de bit u operación NOT, que ya hemos visto
en el contexto clásico.
Y la operación sigma z, o Z,
también se llama inversión de fase.
Y aquí puedes ver la
acción de estas operaciones sobre los vectores de la base estándar, lo que explica un poco
de dónde vienen estos nombres.
Tiene sentido, desde luego,
referirse a sigma x como inversión de bit según esta acción que vemos aquí.
Simplemente invierte el bit de
cero a uno o de uno a cero.
También tiene sentido
llamar a sigma z inversión de fase según esta acción que vemos aquí.
Pero si eso no queda del todo claro
en este momento, no pasa nada.
Nos encontraremos con esta
operación una y otra vez, y la importancia
de poner un signo menos delante del vector de la base ket uno
y no del ket cero
y por qué eso se llama inversión de fase quedará más claro más adelante.
El siguiente ejemplo es
la operación Hadamard, representada por
esta matriz que vemos aquí, que casi siempre se llama H.
Verificar que H es unitaria es una vez más
un cálculo directo, que si me aparto del camino, puedes ver aquí mismo.
Al igual que las matrices de Pauli, H es su propia transpuesta conjugada.
Así que tenemos esta igualdad aquí, y cuando realizamos la multiplicación, obtenemos la matriz identidad como se requiere.
El tercer ejemplo es
en realidad toda una clase de operaciones unitarias
conocidas como operaciones de fase.
Estas son operaciones
representadas por cualquier matriz que tiene esta forma
que ves aquí, donde theta es cualquier número real.
Así que esta entrada aquí siempre será
algún número complejo sobre el círculo unitario.
Las matrices de este tipo son siempre unitarias, lo cual te dejo a ti que lo verifiques.
Esta vez, la transpuesta conjugada no será igual a la matriz original a menos que este número aquí resulte
ser un uno o un menos uno,
en cuyo caso terminamos con
la matriz identidad o sigma z, que ya
hemos encontrado antes.
Concretamente, la transposición
no hace nada a esta matriz, pero tomar el conjugado complejo de cada entrada cambia esta entrada aquí
a e elevado a menos i theta.
Estas dos operaciones en particular son ejemplos especialmente
importantes de operaciones de fase.
Para la primera, tomamos
theta igual a pi sobre dos, y obtenemos esta matriz aquí.
Esta se llama comúnmente una
operación S o un S gate cuando hablamos de circuits, de lo cual no hablaremos en esta lección,
pero es un tema importante
que veremos pronto.
La segunda es esta operación. Es una operación T o un T gate.
Y para esta, theta
es igual a pi sobre cuatro. Entonces, cuando calculamos la exponencial, obtenemos este valor aquí, que es uno más i sobre
la raíz cuadrada de dos.
Aquí hay algunos ejemplos rápidos para ver un par de estas
operaciones en acción.
Esta es la acción de
la operación Hadamard sobre ket cero y ket uno.
Si hacemos la
multiplicación matriz-vector, vemos que lo que obtenemos son el estado más y el
estado menos, respectivamente.
Si aplicamos la operación Hadamard sobre el estado más y el
estado menos, por otro lado, volvemos a ket cero y ket uno.
Entonces, si ordenamos un poco las cosas, podemos ver la acción con más claridad.
La operación Hadamard
transforma de ida y vuelta entre el estado cero y el estado más, y entre el estado uno
y el estado menos.
Con respecto a estas dos ecuaciones aquí, nota que esto nos da una forma simple de detectar la diferencia entre un estado más y un estado menos.
Como vimos antes en la lección, si medimos un estado más
y un estado menos con respecto a la
medición en la base estándar,
obtenemos un bit aleatorio uniforme en ambos casos, lo cual no nos ayuda a
detectar la diferencia.
Pero si aplicamos una operación
Hadamard y luego medimos, veremos un cero si el
estado original era un estado más
y un uno si el estado original
era un estado menos.
Así que estos dos estados son efectivamente distintos, y pueden discriminarse
perfectamente con el método que acabo de describir,
que consiste en primero aplicar
una operación Hadamard y luego medir.
Volviendo al ejemplo de
un estado de qubit que vimos antes y que no es particularmente especial, podemos ver qué hace la operación Hadamard
sobre el estado
convirtiendo a las formas
que ves aquí y realizando la multiplicación.
Y aquí está el resultado,
que podemos convertir de vuelta a la notación de Dirac si queremos,
y esa es una forma de calcular
este tipo de acciones.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo que ilustra que no siempre
hay que convertir explícitamente a la forma de vector matricial.
También puedes realizar estos
cálculos directamente usando la notación de Dirac.
Este ejemplo concierne a la operación T, y aquí está
justo aquí como referencia.
Esta operación tiene esta acción aquí sobre los estados de la base estándar.
Y si queremos calcular
la acción de la operación T sobre un estado más, por ejemplo, podemos comenzar expandiendo la
definición del estado más
y luego usar la linealidad
para expresar el resultado como se ve aquí.
Ahora podemos simplemente sustituir
estas expresiones de arriba, hacer un poco de
simplificación para el segundo término, y obtenemos el resultado.
Si por alguna razón quisiéramos aplicar una operación Hadamard
al resultado, podemos hacer algo similar.
Primero, sustituimos la expresión de T actuando sobre el estado más y usamos la linealidad como hicimos antes.
Y ahora, si sustituimos las
expresiones que ya tenemos para la operación Hadamard
actuando sobre ket cero y ket uno,
obtenemos esto. Y ahora podemos expandir el
estado más y el estado menos para obtener esta expresión aquí,
que podemos simplificar simplemente sumando, y aquí está el resultado final.
No hay nada particularmente
especial en este ejemplo. Solo pretende
ilustrar esta forma alternativa pero equivalente de
calcular las acciones
de estas operaciones. Puedes usar cualquiera de las dos formas
que sea más conveniente en la situación en cuestión.
Un último punto sobre las
operaciones unitarias es que las composiciones de operaciones unitarias
se representan mediante la multiplicación de matrices
igual que en el contexto probabilístico, es decir, puedes calcular la acción de una secuencia de operaciones unitarias
simplemente multiplicando
las matrices entre sí. Y lo que obtendrás es
una única matriz unitaria que representa la acción combinada
de la secuencia de operaciones.
Igual que ocurría con las matrices estocásticas, las matrices unitarias son
cerradas bajo la multiplicación, así que siempre obtendrás una matriz unitaria
cuando compones operaciones unitarias.
Hay que asegurarse de
multiplicar las matrices en el orden correcto.
Pero la forma en que funciona es igual que para
las operaciones estocásticas, donde la matriz para la
primera operación que realizas
siempre aparecerá en el lado derecho
del producto de matrices, y la última aparecerá
en el lado izquierdo.
Así que, igual que antes, el orden está invertido en el sentido de que se compone de derecha a izquierda en lugar de izquierda a derecha.
Aquí hay un ejemplo interesante que da lugar a una operación conocida como la operación raíz cuadrada de not.
Supón que primero
aplicamos una operación Hadamard seguida de una operación S, seguida de otra operación Hadamard.
La acción combinada de
estas tres operaciones está descrita por este producto.
Aquí está la primera operación Hadamard, aquí está la operación S, y aquí está la segunda operación Hadamard.
Si realizamos la multiplicación de matrices, que no se muestra explícitamente aquí, pero puedes hacerlo tú mismo
si quieres,
el resultado es esta matriz aquí. Es una matriz unitaria, y podemos verificarlo directamente
o podemos confiar en el hecho de que las matrices unitarias son
cerradas bajo la multiplicación.
Tiene que ser unitaria porque estas tres matrices son unitarias, como ya hemos visto.
No tenemos ningún vector de
estado cuántico particular en mente aquí.
Podemos imaginar realizar
esta secuencia de operaciones sobre cualquier vector de estado cuántico, y esta matriz describe la acción.
La razón por la que esta operación combinada, es decir, la descrita
por esta matriz aquí, se llama operación raíz cuadrada de not,
es que al realizarla
dos veces, obtenemos una operación not, o en otras palabras, una
operación sigma x o una operación X.
Realizar la operación
dos veces se representa elevando la matriz al cuadrado o
multiplicándola por sí misma.
Y si haces esto, verás que el resultado
es la matriz de Pauli x.
Y eso es bastante peculiar, y te da solo una pista de que puedes hacer cosas interesantes con la información cuántica que no puedes hacer con
la información clásica.
No existe ninguna operación clásica, es decir, una representada
por una matriz estocástica, que nos dé una operación not
si la realizamos dos veces.
Así que es un buen ejemplo que revela que las operaciones cuánticas
se comportan de forma muy diferente a las operaciones clásicas.
Y eso es todo para la lección uno. En esta lección, hablamos sobre cómo funciona la información cuántica para sistemas individuales de forma aislada,
y en la próxima lección, hablaremos sobre cómo
funciona la información cuántica para sistemas múltiples.
Gracias por ver. Si tienes alguna pregunta, no dudes en dejarla en
la sección de comentarios abajo.